avec fatima benomar militante féministe
cofondatrice de l'association les
effrontés bonsoir fatima benomar merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france le
constat fait par marlène schiappa + 30 %
de signalements chez les gendarmes
également chez les policiers une hausse
notable selon vous c'est une hausse
notable et qui montre qu'en fait ces
femmes sont encore plus en danger que
d'habitude parce que quand elle pointe
du doigt le fait qu'elle appelle plutôt
la police que le 39 19 qui n'est qu' un
numéro de réorientation et d'information
ça veut dire qu'elles sont encore plus
dans une situation d'urgence et on leur
dit quand vous êtes en urgence
n'appelait pas à 39,19 appelé la police
déjà en temps normal les violences
faites aux femmes au sein du couple
c'est un fait quand même massif
on compte plus de 200 mille femmes
victimes par an en france mais en plus
avec le confinement c'est à dire avec
des hommes qui ont souvent aussi des
représentations très misogyne très
machiste sur leurs droits à eux de
pouvoir sortir quand ils veulent rentrer
à l'heure qu'ils veulent bas ces hommes
qui ont qui sont déjà assez misogyne qui
se retrouve enfermé vont remporté plus
ruminer et se défouler sur sur les
femmes et c'est ainsi qu'on va les voir
d'abord leur imposer des violences
psychologiques c'est à dire les dénigrer
critiquer leurs faits et gestes à
l'intérieur est d'autant plus se passer
à des passages à l'acte physique
sexuelle etc
donc c'est vrai que c'est un moment de
crise qui aggrave encore plus les
violences et de femmes et parmi ces
signalements il ya des femmes qui
étaient déjà battus et maltraités avant
mais là comme elle non plus
d'échappatoire elles peuvent plus aller
se réfugier chez leurs parents le temps
que ça se calme ou chez leurs amis
elles vont appeler le 17 parce qu'elle
se retrouve vraiment en danger et le
fait de ne pas pouvoir appeler le 39 19
c'est aussi le manque de 2,2
moyens privés de s'isoler pour pouvoir
appeler ce numéro c'est révélateur du
confinement
effectivement nous les associations
féministes ce qui nous met hors de nous
c'est que déjà c'est censé être la
grande cause nationale
et là en plus on est en temps de crise
c'est à dire que le fait massif des
violences faites aux femmes au sein du
couple est aggravée et au lieu d'étendre
l'amplitude horaire du 39 19 qui est qui
étaient ouverts jeu avant jusqu'à 22
heures
la faute de moyens on l'aurait pris 6 et
maintenant ils ferment à 19 heures alors
que déjà à la sortie du grenelle on vous
avait promis on allait passer à 1 39 19
7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
pourquoi est-ce que le 39 19 n'a pas
embauché à cette personne faute de
moyens et que les percées personnes ne
peuvent pas se relayer pour assurer pour
assurer que le 39 19 soit accessible à
tous le temps le gouvernement vient de
mettre plusieurs milliards sur la table
dont deux seulement par hiéro soignants
et nous les féministes on me demandait
qu'un seul des milliards ce qui déjà
semblé il ya quelques temps faramineux
ce qu'on demande c'est que puisque
maintenant il est en train d'identifier
tous ceux qui s'aggrave sur le plan par
exemple sanitaires sur le plan
économique dans la société
et puisqu'il reconnaît qu est-ce qui
s'aggrave ce sont les violences faites
aux femmes et bien qu'ils mettre
l'argent sur la table
la ministre préconise d des points de
contact temporaires dans les centres
commerciaux ça veut dire que ce serait
donc ces femmes l'un qui pourrait sortir
alors les situations sont diverses
il ya des femmes qui justement sont
doublement confiné à la fois par la
crise sanitaire est à la fois par leur
conjoint violent qui vont aller
surveiller les empêcher de sortir et
c'est pour certes ces femmes qui peuvent
quand même de temps en temps sortir du
domicile c'est toujours bien qu'ils
aient ces points de contact
maintenant c'est toujours la même
histoire c'est la formation des
personnes qui les accueillent c'est à
dire que même la police qui est censée
être la plus formés à l'accueil des
femmes victimes de violences on l'a
assez dénoncé elle les accueille mal
elles refusent leur plainte si elle
n'arrive pas avec un oeil au beurre noir
elle leur accorde pas de crédibilité
alors vous imaginez
je sais pas une personne qui est dans
une grande surface où la grande
distribution je sais pas comment elles
seront accueillies
donc ce qu'il faut d'autant plus c'est
des agents formés qui vont les prendre
au sérieux toutes les femmes victimes de
violences n'ont pas de dents en moins et
un coquard énorme et les les appels
reçus par la gendarmerie et la police en
temps normal se font pas forcément
traiter correctement mais elles sont
traitées et là comment faire comment est
ce que la police ou les gendarmes
interviennent elles sont pas toujours
traitées alors que ces hors la loi
plusieurs policiers décourage les femmes
de porter plainte
avec ces fameuses phrases qui reviennent
vous êtes sûr vous voulez vraiment
mettre en prison le père de votants deux
enfants est malheureusement ça ce sont
les réseaux où on l'a donc bah
maintenant j'espère que le message qui a
été médiatisé va d'autant plus les
responsabiliser un accueil
inconditionnel et il faut que les femmes
quand elles sortent pas puisque
maintenant il ya déjà des agents des
policiers qui sont dans l'espace public
pour contrôler les attestations
ben si une femme encore une fois même si
elle n'a pas l'air selon les stéréotypes
battue va avoir un agent et lui dit là
je peux pas rentrer chez moi j'ai pris
l'attestation j'ai coché au hasard une
case
mais je me sens en danger il faut pas
qu'il leur dise non mais madame c'est la
crise sanitaire rentrez chez vous on
veut pas l'entendre il faut qu'ils les
prennent au sérieux et qui les
accueillent et qui les orientent comme
avant et même encore plus on voit que ce
confinement on a le cas de la chine où
il ya davantage de divorce à au sortir
de ce confinement est ce que cette crise
finalement pour révéler aussi des cas de
violence qui d'ordinaire n'aurait pas eu
lieu
effectivement on sait que dans les
toutes les crises qu'elles soient
économiques qu'elles soient sanitaires
ou même les crises
à titre personnel c'est à dire des
licenciements etc ce sont des moments
qui vont aggraver les violences
intrafamiliales et conduire les femmes
par exemple à partir à quitter leur
conjoint violent
elle est divorcée d'ailleurs c'est
souvent là où elles sont le plus en
danger c'est au moment où les femmes
victimes de violence quitte le conjoint
violent qu'il faut vraiment assurer leur
protection
parce que c'est là où les conjoints
violents avec les plombs et envie de le
retrouver et de commettre le geste fatal
le féminicide donc c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut non seulement que la police
soit disponibles et formés et il faut
que ces femmes là soient protégés c'est
à dire que les les juges aux affaires
familiales par exemple continue malgré
la crise sanitaire a donné des
ordonnances de protection et à assurer
la sécurité des femmes qui décident de
partir c'est pas parce qu'on part qu'on
est sorti d'affaires malheureusement
loin glas merci fatima benomar d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france